Estamos en el problema 27 y me dice,
¿Cuál es la ecuación que mejor
representa a la recta siguiente?
Y bueno tenemos justo esta recta aquí, en esta gráfica.
Y antes de ver las respuestas quiero que pensemos un poco en la gráfica que tenemos representada justo aquí.
¿Cuál es nuestra intersección con el eje de la "y"?
Bueno, si esta recta tiene como ecuación
a "y" es igual a "mx" más "b",
dónde recuerda que la "m" es la pendiente y "b" es la intersección con el eje de la "y".
Bueno, si te das cuenta, aquí intersectamos
al eje de la "y" en el valor de 0,
cuando "x" vale 0, "y"vale 0,
estamos justo en este punto de aquí,
intersectamos al eje de la "y" en el origen y por lo tanto, puede decir que "b" vale 0.
Cuando "x" vale 0, "y" vale 0 y entonces esta
ecuación se va a simplificar de la siguiente manera,
"y" es igual a "m" por "x", porque la
intersección con el eje de la "y" es 0.
Ahora, para sacar la pendiente, recuerda que
la podemos obtener pensando en el cambio en
"y" con respecto al cambio en "x",
así que vamos a fijarnos como cambia esta recta.
Si nosotros nos movemos una en dirección en "x",
¿cuánto vamos a cambiar en "y"?
Bueno podemos crecer o decrecer,
sin embargo, esta recta crece. Y crece si te das cuenta
hasta acá, hasta el valor de 2, por lo tanto,
cuando cambiamos en "y" a... esto lo puedo
poner así, cuando tenemos un cambio en "y"
de dos unidades, entonces cambiamos en "x"
una unidad... cambiamos en "x" una unidad,
por lo tanto la pendiente es 2 sobre 1,
lo cual es 2.
Y ahora sí, puedo decir que esta recta tiene
como ecuación, "y" es igual a "2x"... a "2x"
porque estoy sustituyendo la pendiente y si
te das cuenta, es justo mi inciso b.
Mi inciso b me dice que "y" es igual a "2x".
Por lo tanto,  ya está la respuesta de este
el problema número 27 y lo voy a quitar justo de aquí para poner el siguiente problema.
Voy a poner ahora el problema número 28.
Y el problema número 28, lo tengo justo aquí.
¿Cuál de los siguientes puntos se encuentra en la recta definida por la ecuación "3x" más "6y" esto es igual a 2?
Y bueno, si te das cuenta aquí tengo cuatro
puntos y creo que la forma más fácil que
se me ocurre de resolver este problema es
sustituir cada uno de los puntos para ver
cual cumple esta ecuación que tengo aquí,
por ejemplo, tengo el punto A,
que dice que cuando "x" vale 0, "y" vale 2 y si lo sustituyo
en esta ecuación de aquí arriba,
me va a quedar lo siguiente,
3 que multiplica a 0 más 6 que multiplica a 2.
Y bueno, esto es lo mismo que 3 por 0 = 0 más 12, bueno, esto es 12, lo cuál en definitiva no es 2.
Por lo tanto, el inciso A ya puedo decir que
no es mi solución.
Vamos a intentar hacer lo mismo con el inciso B.
Cuando "x" vale 0, "y" vale 6 y por lo tanto
voy a sustituir en esta recta
que tengo aquí arriba, 3 por 0, ok,
y a esto le vamos a sumar, 6 veces el valor
de "y", pero el valor de "y" es 6 entonces,
6 por 6, y bueno, esto es lo mismo que 3 por
0 = 0 más 6 por 6 = 36.
36, lo cual no es dos.
Por lo tanto, tampoco es el inciso B.
Vamos a probar con el inciso C.
Me quedaría 3 por 1 que es el valor de "x"
más 6 que multiplica al valor de "y" que
en este caso es -1/6... -1/6.
Y bueno, ¿esto a cuánto es igual?
Esto es lo mismo que 3... 3 más 6 por -1/6,
más por menos es menos, por lo tanto aquí
me quedaría menos, y 6 por 1/6 es lo mismo
que uno, por lo tanto me queda 3 menos 1,
lo cual... de lujo, sí es 2.
Ya tenemos la respuesta, la respuesta es el inciso C...
el inciso C que es el punto 1, -1/6
y este punto se encuentra justo en esta recta.
Muy bien, voy a quitar este problema y ahora vamos a resolver el siguiente problema. El problema 29.
29, ¿Cuál es la ecuación de la recta que
tiene una pendiente de 4 y pasa por el punto 3, -10?
Y bueno, lo que sabemos es que tiene una pendiente de 4, así que vamos a utilizar eso.
Si la recta, esta recta, tiene como ecuación
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b", lo que ya sabemos
es cuánto vale la pendiente,
la pendiente vale 4 que es justo lo que nos dicen.
Por lo tanto esto nos quedaría "y" es igual
a 4 que multiplica a "x" más "b".
Y lo que necesitamos saber es el valor de "b", de la intersección con el eje de la "y".
Y bueno, para esto voy a utilizar este punto
que tengo aquí.
El cuál nos da la siguiente información,
cuando "x" vale 3, "y" vale -10 y es un punto
que pasa por ésta recta.
Por lo tanto, ¿qué te parece si sustituimos?
Cuando "y" vale -10, ok, entonces tomamos
el valor de 3 en "x", 4 por 3, ok, más "b",
ok, pero 4 por 3 es 12, entonces me quedaría
-10 es igual a 12, ok, más "b".
Y ahora, si queremos despejar a "b" lo que
tenemos que hacer es restar 12 de ambos lados.
Y me va a quedar que "b" es igual a -10 menos
-12, lo cual es -22,
pase este 12 el otro lado restando o reste 12 de ambos lados, y ya tengo el valor de "b".
"b" vale -22, por lo tanto esta recta se ve
de la forma "y" es igual a "4x" más "b",
pero "b2 vale -22... -22, de lujo.
Y si te das cuenta, es justo el inciso A.
Por lo tanto, la respuesta de este problema
es el inciso A.
Vamos a resolver el problema número 30.
Ya está por aquí.
El problema número 30, que es éste.
Los datos de la tabla siguiente muestran el
costo de rentar una bicicleta por hora,
incluyendo el depósito.
Rentar una bicicleta y aquí tengo una tabla.
Cuando rento la bicicleta 2 horas,
el costo en pesos es de 15 pesos.
Cuando la rento 5 horas es de 30 pesos.
8 horas es de 45 pesos.
Si las horas , "h", estuvieran graficadas en el eje horizontal, ok, eso es importante, y el costo, "c",
estuviera graficado en el eje vertical, ok.
¿Cuál sería la ecuación de la recta
que se ajuste a los datos?
Y bueno, lo primero que se me ocurre
es utilizar esta información,
"h" está en el eje horizontal y "c" está en el eje vertical,
déjame ver si lo puedo representar más o menos así.
Por aquí tengo al eje horizontal y este eje
horizontal está representado por "h", ok,
mientras que por aquí tengo a mi eje vertical,
ok, más o menos se ve algo así y está representado
por "c", éste está representado por "c".
Por lo tanto "h" ocupa el lugar de "x" y "c"
ocupa el lugar de "y",
por lo tanto podríamos decir que la función del costo va a depender de "h" y se va a ver más o menos así.
"c" es igual a "m" por "h" más "b" porque
recuerda que es una función lineal y además
nos están diciendo que "h" representa a las
"x" en esta oración que tengo aquí
y "c" representa a las "y" en esta oración que
tengo justo aquí.
Y bueno, si nosotros queremos calcular la
pendiente, recuerda que la pendiente va a
ser igual al cambio, en este caso, al cambio
en la variable "c"...
al cambio en la variable "c", con respecto al cambio en la variable "h", es decir, cuánto cambiamos de aquí
por acá, a comparación de cuanto cambiamos
de aquí para acá.
Y bueno, si sustituimos esto me quedaría,
si nos fijamos primero en cuanto cambiamos
en las horas pasamos de 2 a 5, lo podríamos
escribir así, 5 menos 2, ok.
Y ahora si nos fijamos cuánto cambiamos en
el costo, bueno, pasamos de 15 a 30,
lo podemos escribir como 30 menos 15, ok, y esto es lo
mismo que, 30 menos 15, lo cual es 15, ok,
y 5 menos 2 lo cual es 3.
Por lo tanto, la pendiente es 5.
De lujo, ya tenemos la pendiente y la voy
a ocupar justo aquí.
En lugar de poner "m" voy a poner que "c"
es igual a "mh", es decir,
5 por "h", porque ya obtuve la pendiente más "b".
Y ahora, para obtener a "b" podemos utilizar
cualquier de estos puntos como le hice en
el ejercicio pasado, de hecho, se me ocurre
utilizar mejor este primer punto, el cual
me dice que cuando "h" vale 2, "c" vale 15...
cuando "c" vale 15, "h" vale 2,
5 por 2 más "b".
Ok, déjame bajar un poco la pantalla, para
tener un poco más de espacio...
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla... déjame
bajarla un poco más y ok,
aquí voy a obtener el valor de "b".
Para obtener el valor de "b" vamos a multiplicar
5 por 2 y voy a decir que 15 es igual a 10
más "b" y ahora si resto 10 de ambos lados,
voy a obtener que "b" es igual a 15 menos
10, lo cual es 5, de lujo.
Ya tengo "b", ya tengo la pendiente y ahora
sí, puedo decir que la función del costo...
la función del costo que depende de "h" es
lo mismo que 5 veces "h",
la pendiente por "h", más "b", pero "b" vale también 5.
Y si nos damos cuenta,
es justo ésta que tenemos aquí, es el inciso C, "c" es igual a "5h" más 5 y esta es nuestra respuesta.
Ahora, tú podrías verificar utilizando los
otros puntos, para ver que en efecto,
es justo esta la ecuación que estábamos buscando,
pero bueno, es hora de quitar este problema.
Y voy a trabajar con el siguiente problema,
el problema número 31...
el problema número 31 y lo tengo justo por acá.
Dice, algunos pares ordenados de la función lineal de "x" se muestran a continuación,
y si te das cuenta nos dan una tabla.
¿Cuál de las siguientes ecuaciones se usó
para generar la tabla anterior?
Ok, es justo igual al problema anterior, es
muy parecido, lo que tenemos que hacer es
tomarnos una función "y" que es igual "mx"
más "b" que genera esta tabla pero si te das cuenta,
nos dicen que es una función
lineal y por lo tanto la podemos representar
con esta expresión de aquí, no tenemos nada
raro como una "x" cuadrada o lo que sea.
Y ahora, lo que necesitamos sacar, en primer
lugar es la pendiente pero recuerda que la
pendiente es lo mismo que el cambio en "y"
con respecto al cambio en "x".
Así que vamos a fijarnos cuanto cambiamos,
en este caso vamos a cambiar de 1 a 3, ok,
entonces el cambio en "x" me quedaría bajo
3 menos 1, ok, mientras que el cambio en "y"
va de 1 a 7, me quedaría arriba 7 menos 1
y esto es lo mismo que 6 entre 2, ok, si te das cuenta de aquí para acá cambiamos 2
unidades y de aquí para acá
cambiamos 6 unidades y bueno,
esto quiere decir que la
pendiente vale 3, ¡perfecto!
Ya tenemos que la pendiente vale 3 y entonces
tengo la ecuación "y" es igual a 3 por "x" más "b".
Y de igual manera, como en el ejercicio pasado,
vamos a sustituir alguno de estos valores
que me dan.
Y de hecho creo que éste es el más fácil,
cuando "x" vale 1, "y" vale 1, así que lo
voy a utilizar justo aquí... cuando "y" vale
1, "x" vale 1... 3 por 1, ok... más "b"
y entonces de aquí voy a obtener que 1 es igual
a 3 más "b", ok, y si de aquí resto 3 de ambos lados,
voy a obtener que "b" es igual
a 1 menos 3, lo cual es -2, ok.
Vamos a utilizar toda esta información para
encontrar la ecuación que yo estoy buscando.
"y" es igual a la pendiente pero mi pendiente
vale 3 por "x" y a esto hay que sumarle "b",
pero "b" vale -2.
Ok y si te das cuenta es justo el inciso C.
El inciso C me dice que "y" es igual a "3x"
menos 2 y ya está mi siguiente respuesta.
Ya tengo la respuesta de este
problema número 31 y bueno,
creo que tengo tiempo todavía
de resolver un problema más.
Por lo tanto, déjame quitar este problema de aquí y vamos a resolver el último problema.
Problema número 32, lo tengo justo por acá.
La ecuación de la recta "l" es "6x" más
"5y" igual a 3,
y la ecuación de la recta "q" es
igual a "5x" menos "6y" es igual a 0.
¿Cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones sobre
estas dos rectas es verdadera?
Inciso A. La recta "l" y la recta "q" tienen
la misma intersección con el eje "y".
Inciso B. Las rectas "l" y "q" son paralelas.
Inciso C. La recta "l" y la recta "q" tienen la misma intersección con el eje "x".
Y bueno, aquí tengo el inciso D, que dice, las rectas "l" y "q" son perpendiculares.
Recuerda, dos rectas son perpendiculares si la pendiente de una...
es el inverso multiplicativo
negativo de la pendiente de la otra.
Pero bueno, como no sé cuál es de estos
incisos mi respuesta correcta, vamos a trabajar
con estas dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí.
Yo prefiero verlas en la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen porque así es mucho más fácil
visualizarlas y trabajar con ellas,
así que trabajemos primero con la recta "l" y vamos
a pasarla a la forma pendiente ordenada al origen.
La recta "l" tiene como ecuación "6x" más 5 veces "y", esto es igual a 3, ok.
Y bueno, si de aquí quiero despejar a "y" para obtener la forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
voy a restar "6x" de ambos lados
y voy a obtener que 5 veces "y",
es lo mismo que -6 veces "x", ok,
y a esto le sumo 3, de lujo.
Y ahora, voy a dividir todo entre 5.
Y entonces me va a quedar que "y" es igual...
y voy a obtener -6 entre 5, ok,
todo lo estoy dividiendo entre 5 que multiplica a "x" más
3 entre 5... 3 entre 5, ok.
Ya tengo a la recta "l" lista en su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen.
Y que te parece si hacemos lo mismo con la recta "q".
La recta "q" tiene como ecuación, 5 veces
"x" menos 6 veces "y", esto es igual a 0, ok.
Y si de aquí quiero despejar a "y", voy a restar "5x" de ambos lados y voy a obtener -6 veces "y", ok,
esto es igual a -5 veces "x" estoy pasando este del otro lado con signo contrario
y ahora voy a dividir todo entre -6
y voy a obtener que "y" es lo mismo que...
y aquí hay que tener cuidado, -5 entre -6
es lo mismo que 5/6 positivo,
porque menos
entre menos me da más, 5/6 "x", ok.
Y si ahora visualizo estas dos rectas,
estas dos ecuaciones
en su forma pendiente ordenada al origen detenidamente... ahh... ¡wow!
Ya te diste cuenta, es justo de lo que
hablábamos hace rato.
Si te das cuenta la pendiente de ésta,
es el inverso multiplicativo de la pendiente
de ésta, pero con signo contrario.
Y recuerda que dos rectas perpendiculares
cumplen esa particularidad, que si nos tomamos
la pendiente de una, ok, en este caso es 5/6
y a esta pendiente, le buscamos su inverso
multiplicativo, que en este caso sería 6/5
y le cambiamos de signo, es decir, -6/5,
entonces obtenemos la pendiente de la
otra recta que es perpendicular.
Y eso es justo lo que habíamos probado en
los videos anteriores.
Así que, bueno, ya puedo concluir que estas
dos rectas, la recta "l" y la recta "q" son
rectas perpendiculares y es justo la solución
de este último problema.
El problema número 32, tiene como
respuesta el inciso D.
Así que ya hemos acabado y nos vemos en el
siguiente video.